[Applause]
can i hold it
and if you promise to be really really
careful i promise
i will be so incredibly careful
i will be incredibly careful with that
okay i promise all right
so it's slippery be careful
all right are you ready
i'm about to touch a one kilogram sphere
of silicon 28 atoms they're about 2.15
times 10 to the 25 of them
it feels absolutely incredible wow
that is amazing besides its creators i
am one of only a handful of people
ever to hold this sphere the raw
material used to make it was worth
1 million euros but now that it has been
so precisely sculpted
how much is that worth it's priceless
this you're looking at now is the
roundest
object in the world how can you say for
sure that it's the roundest object
i mean the earth is pretty grand isn't
it if this
was the earth if this were the earth in
the highest mountain and the lowest
valley would be
about 14 meters apart
[Laughter]
that is shocking that is shockingly
round
but why would you invest 1 million euros
and thousands of man hours perfecting a
pure
polished silicon sphere well the answer
is
grey or rather
grav as it would have been pronounced in
the original french you see the graph
was the original name for the base unit
of mass in the metric system
which became the system internationale
dunite
or si units in 1793 a commission which
included notable scientists and
aristocrat antoine lavoisier
defined the base unit of mass as the
weight of a cubic decimeter of water at
the melting temperature of ice
essentially just a liter of ice water
the name grav came from the latin
gravitas meaning weight
but it wasn't to last it sounded too
similar to the aristocratic title
graph which is the equivalent of an earl
or account
and with the french revolution in full
swing with a rallying cry of equality
for all
you couldn't exactly have one unit
nobler than the others
at this lavoisier lost his head
literally
not because he helped devise one of the
greatest systems of measurement of all
time
but because he was collecting taxes as a
nobleman
so things really were grave the new
republican government
believed a grav would be too big for the
things they wanted to measure anyway
and so they settled on a gram which was
just a thousandth of a grav
but soon they realized that a gram was
too small and so they returned to the
grav
but since they couldn't call it that
they invented the kilogram
a thousand grams and that is why
out of the seven base si units the
kilogram is the only one to have a
prefix in its name
in 1799 the kilogram definition was
refined to be
the mass of a liter of water at four
degrees celsius
the temperature at which it is densest
but water itself
is obviously not the most sensible thing
to use as a mass standard
so a pure platinum cylinder was created
to have the same mass
as the water definition and it was
declared kilogram of the archives
now it's important to note at this point
the kilogram is no longer tied to the
mass of a volume of water
the kilogram of the archives is by
definition
the kilogram 90 years later in 1889 the
kilogram was upgraded to a platinum
iridium alloy cylinder
now it was much harder than the original
but was otherwise basically identical
and to this day it remains the
definition of the kilogram
it is officially called the
international prototype kilogram
though it's affectionately known as
legrand k or
big k o and it's about this big
it is the only thing in the entire
universe with a mass
of exactly one kilogram because it is
the kilogram it is also the only si unit
that is still defined by a physical
object
it sits under three bell jars next to
six
sister kilograms in a climate-controlled
vault
locked by three independently controlled
keys in the basement of the
international bureau of weights and
measures on the outskirts of paris
now if you were able to break into the
vault and tamper with big k
you would actually be changing the
definition of the kilogram
a definition on which many of our
measurements rely
and so you would throw the world into
chaos
well no not actually but how would
anyone ever
know if the mass of big k changed
well when it was first created 40
identical replicas were also made
well they weren't quite identical they
had a mass which was slightly different
to big k
but those offsets were recorded now
these replicas were sent out to
countries around the world to serve as
their national standards
in 1948 the kilograms were reunited for
a weigh-in
and this is when the problem started
because
even though all the cylinders were made
of the same alloy
and stored under virtually the same
conditions
their masses had diverged over time
the mass of big k wasn't even the same
as the six sister cylinders stored with
it and to make matters worse when they
were brought together again 40 years
later
their masses had further diverged up to
about 50 micrograms
that's about the weight of a fingerprint
but fingerprints were not the culprits
since the kilograms were carefully
washed before their weigh-ins
so some physical process must have
actually changed the mass
of the cylinders but how that exactly
works remains a matter of speculation
one thing is for certain the mass of a
platinum iridium cylinder is not stable
over time and this is a big problem you
can't have a unit which changes its
value
and the fallout isn't limited to
measurements of mass since
of the seven base si units four of them
depend on the mass of the kilogram not
to mention all the derived units like
newtons jewels
volts and watts at this point those of
you in countries that have not adopted
the metric system
yes i'm speaking to you liberia burma
and the u.s
you may be feeling rather smug that your
base unit of mass the avoid
pound is no longer defined by a physical
object no instead it is defined as
precisely
nine 0.453592 three seven kilograms
sucked in so clearly something needs to
be done to eliminate the kilograms
dependence on a physical object
and this is where the silicon sphere
comes in but
how exactly does that help here you have
a physical object and it's beautiful but
you know it's still a physical object
you're trying to
get away from that we're trying to get
away from the physical object but what
we're doing with this particular
object is counting how many atoms
are in there you can't actually count
how many are in there can you
you can't count how many are in there
but you can calculate how many are in
there because
this material is silicon there's no
voids or dislocations so this is like a
perfect crystal of silicon
that's right not only is it pure silicon
it contains
only one isotope of silicon silicon 28
and that explains why the original
material was so expensive and why a
sphere
well a sphere is a pretty simple
object if you know the diameter of the
sphere you can characterize
the entire dimension of the object well
that explains why the sphere has to be
the roundest object
ever created but how do you actually
make something that round
we actually start with an oversized
sphere
so it was about two millimeters larger
in diameter
and then we just grind it progressively
finer and finer
using abrasive it's actually massaging
atoms you're down at that level of
trying to control the shape
of an object down at the atomic level
but making the sphere is only half the
battle
then you need to accurately measure its
diameter the diameter is actually
measured via
a laser so you're actually measuring
having the sphere in the center of a
cavity and a laser is hitting
both sides and you're actually measuring
the gap by knowing the diameter you can
determine its volume
and since the atom spacing of silicon is
known to high precision
you can then calculate how many atoms
make up the sphere
this allows you to redefine avogadro's
constant
at the moment avogadro's constant is
defined based on the kilogram
it is equal to the number of atoms in 12
grams of carbon-12
but using this approach the number of
silicon atoms in the sphere would be
used to fix
avogadro's constant which would then
define the kilogram
so even if the silicon spheres were lost
or damaged
it would have no effect on the
definition of the kilogram
because it would be defined not by a
physical object but by a concept
if you would like to see the official
definition of the kilogram say a
kilogram
is the mass of 2.15 times 10 to the 25
silicon
28 atoms yes is it
there's a there's a likelihood a high
likelihood that it's going to happen
but there is another approach to
redefining the kilogram
which involves fixing planks constant
and it's done using something called a
watt balance
these two approaches are complementary
each one
provides a check on the other and if
they show good agreement
and are able to bring their
uncertainties down to about 20
micrograms
they may redefine the kilogram as early
as 2014
and then the kilogram finally will be an
unchanging unit
no longer defined by a physical object
in the basement
vault of some place in paris
now if the kilogram was originally
intended to be the mass of a liter of
water at its densest temperature
then how well did we do well if you look
at a liter of water at nearly 4 degrees
celsius it has a mass
of 999.975
grams so i guess you could look at this
two ways
on the one hand you could say the
kilogram is slightly heavier than it
should be
but on the other hand 214 years ago
scientists were able to create an
artifact that was correct
within the margin of error of a grain of
rice
now that is truly remarkable
now if you want to hear more about the
walk balance let me know in the comments
and i will see what i can do
it does seem to be the front runner in
terms of redefining the kilogram
so we will have to wait and see what
happens
one last thing i should point out that
it took an international collaboration
of scientists to create the silicon
sphere
but don't you think that the scientist
who originally conceived of
silicon as an element should receive
some of the credit well in 1787
that was none other than antoine
lavoisier so he's been involved in the
definition of a kilogram from start to
finish
or from cradle to grave